in a career that spans over fifty films
and three and a half decades this is the
shot in Yasuhiro azuz filmography that's
inspired the most discussion a vase a
vase in the dark of a room at a Kyoto in
backed by a latticed framed window and
the blurred shadows of bamboo gently
swaying in the night in the room are a
father and daughter enjoying their final
days together before the daughter Noriko
will marry and move out Noriko isn't
keen to marry reluctant to leave her
widower father alone but he insists
refusing to hold his daughter back from
the life she deserves it's pretty clear
that neither father nor daughter really
want this change the two are happy
together but he feels pressure both
societal and personal to find her a
husband before it's too late
and she feels the same pressures to
ascend they're doing what neither of
them won what would both feel the other
needs and expects you can read this as a
tragedy of conservative values or a
necessary if sad part of the human life
cycle children breaking away from
parents to start their own families
eventually becoming parents of children
who grow up and break away and so on and
so on
Oh sue returns again and again to this
transitional moment of marriage and no
one has ever been better at capturing
the melancholy of that generational
rupture for Oh sue marriage can be a
kind of death especially for women like
Noriko in post-war Japan whose life will
probably become defined by her role as
wife as critic Robin wood points out
it's a death of identity and marriage
depicting the split of parent and child
also prefigures the more permanent split
of a parent eventually passing away of a
real death to come now while this is
definitely a bummer and I hope all your
marriages are happy ones Oh sue does
capture something Universal about
change in families a bittersweetness
that you can see in the tears of any
parent at their child's wedding
it's just that in this film late spring
hosszú leans into the bitter and he
really makes you feel it which brings me
back to the vase the shot appears during
a key scene in late spring when Noriko
finally accepts that everything will
change
at first she was resistant than angry at
being pressured jealous at the prospect
of her father remarrying now on the
short trip to Kyoto after she's agreed
to be married her anger and jealousy
have faded and quietly chatting after a
lovely day she lets herself feel the
sadness of the coming loss the new
person to see what those are not to talk
to me yet at Kentucky
[Music]
the cut to the Vaes is so striking here
because it arrives at exactly the moment
of emotional transition as Donald
Ritchie notes what we would expect for a
filmmaker to do is hold on Mariko's face
as the smile fades into a frown so that
we can take that emotional journey with
her instead Oh sue interrupts that
journey and substitutes this object it's
such an unusual decision that every azu
film scholar almost as a rite of passage
has to take a crack at what it means for
Richie being shown the Vaes at these
crucial seconds forces the viewer to
imagine Noriko's feelings rather than
watch them having put ourselves in her
position when azu returns to her face
near tears the emotion becomes as real
for us as it is for her Paul Schrader
before becoming her writer and director
in his own right theorized that the vase
was a sign of azouz transcendental style
were already thinking of Mariko's loss
in cutting to this image of stasis azu
triggers a deeper zen-like contemplation
not just of this specific situation but
of the transience of all things of
ephemerality as the truth of life for
David Bordwell the vase is an example of
AA zoo's formal playfulness by cutting
to something that is clearly not in
noriko x' line of sight he's blocking us
from the subjectivity of a normal POV
shot thus entering our viewing
experience or that we can consider the
story from various angles and not just
from noriko x' perspective Kristin
Thompson believes the vase is an
arbitrary object a non narrative element
wedged into the action she says used to
prevent us from feeling too deeply at
this moment so that our emotion is not
wasted for what she believes is the real
climax in the following scene the
convict step 9 course this linear attack
ad for philosopher Jill Dollaz the vase
is a representation of time itself
because it is a still image that does
not change the only thing that moves
here is the passage of time something
that's made more explicit by the shots
that come before and after this is
important because human consciousness is
a function of time time is what the mind
is made of so for a few seconds this
shot allows us to observe that basic
medium in its pure form to assume a
shigeki Co the influential Japanese film
critic it's peculiar that we even
consider this a shot of a phase when
there are so many other things in the
frame like the Shoji window and the
shadows of the bamboos assume Lee
challenges our impulse to immediately
interpret this image and asks us simply
to look at it to live within that
looking to experience the vanishing of
ourselves
[Music]
[Music]
I find all of these readings compelling
they speak to the unique power that owes
who has that he developed over his long
career his style may appear simple but
as in fact so finely tuned so carefully
calibrated that he has the power to
overwhelm the viewer to launch a
thousand interpretations with a single
[Music]
cut hey everybody thank you so much for
watching this episode was sponsored by
Ray Khan if you don't know ray Kahn
makes innovative ear buds at really good
prices I've been using their latest
model the everyday e25 for the last few
weeks and I love them they're
comfortable in the ear they look sleek
and they sound great this new model has
more bass which is really good for
listening to music myself I am
constantly listening to audiobooks so I
put these every day.you 25s through
their paces
they have six hours of play time which
is perfect for what I need after a few
minutes I even forget they're in there
and yes I do read and listen at the same
time it helps me focus try it go to buy
rake on.com slash nerdwriter to get
fifteen percent off your order rate kind
of earbuds start at about half the price
of other premium wireless earbuds and
sound just as amazing thanks guys I'll
see you next time